I've used the same three pillar
framework for a very long time and
that's how I've been able to scale ads
even though I'm not the best copywriter
and it goes what who when what is you've
got the four elements of the value
equation and then you've got their
counterparts so you've got dream outcome
you've got nightmare you've got time
delay you've got speed you've got
perceived like you've achievement you've
got risk effort sacrifice you've got
ease and so that gives you eight
variables to talk about your product or
service through now that's the what then
you have the perspective from which do
you want to show that benefit so it
could be from the prospect it could be
from the prospect's wife it could be
from their kids perspective their
colleague's perspective their friend's
perspective and that gives you another
huge series of lenses to look at those
eight through if your wife is proud of
you for tightening your belt one Loop
because you lost weight it hits
different than if it's your colleague or
your kid the third lens is in what time
period because you can future Pace or
you can pass or you can present pain or
pleasure put those three together it
gives you endless ways to describe the
benefits of choosing you and the cost of
staying the same so that you can make
unlimited ads and hooks that are
relevant and will hit different chords
with different people